- [Voiceover] So we're told
that F of two is equal to 12,
F prime of X is equal to
24 over X to the third
and what we want to figure out
is what is F of negative one.
Alright, so they give us the
derivative in terms of X.
So maybe we could take the anti-derivative
of the derivative to find
our original function.
So let's do that.
So we could say that F of X,
F of X is going to be equal
to the anti-derivative
or we could say the indefinite
integral of F prime of X,
which is equal to 24 over X to the third.
I could write it over like
this, 24 over X to the third.
But to help me process
it a little bit more,
I'm gonna write this as
24 X to the negative three
'cause then it'll become how
to take that anti-derivative.
D, DX.
And so what is the anti-derivative
of 24X to the negative three?
Well we're just going to do
the power rule in reverse.
So what we're going to do
is we're going to increase the exponent.
So let me just rewrite it.
It's going to be 24X to the,
we're going to increase
the exponent by one,
so it's gonna be X to the
negative three plus one
and then we're going to divide
by that increased exponent.
So negative three plus one
and so that is going to be
negative three plus one
is X to the negative two
and then we divide by negative two
and if you're in doubt
about what we just did
where we're kind of doing
the power rule in reverse,
now take the derivative of
this using the power rule.
Negative two times 24 over negative two
is just gonna be 24 and then
you decrement that exponent,
you go to negative three.
So are we done here, is this F of X?
Well F of X might involve a constant.
So let's put a constant out here
because notice if you were to take
the derivative of this thing here,
the derivative of 24X to the
negative two over negative two
we already established is
24X to the negative three.
But then if you take the
derivative of a constant,
well that just disappears.
So you don't see it when
you look at the derivative.
So we have to make sure that
there might be a constant
and I have a feeling based
on the information that
they've given us, we're going
to make use of that constant.
So let me rewrite F of X.
So we know that F of X can be expressed as
24 divided by negative two.
It's negative 12X to the
negative two plus some constant.
So how do we figure out that constant?
Well they have told us what F of two is.
F of two is equal to 12.
So let's write this down.
So F of two is equal to 12,
which is equal to well we
just have to put two in
everywhere we see an X.
That's going to be negative two
times two to the negative two power plus C
and so 12 is equal to, what is this,
two to the negative two.
Two to the negative two is
equal to one over two squared,
which is equal to 1/4.
So this is negative 12 times 1/4.
Negative 12 times 1/4 is negative three.
So it's negative three plus C.
Now we can add three to
both sides to solve or C.
We get 15 is equal to C.
So or C is equal to 15.
That is equal to 15.
And so now we can write our F of X
as we get F of X is equal to negative 12
and I could even write that as
negative 12 over X squared if we like.
Negative 12 over X squared plus 15
and now using that we can
evaluate F of negative one.
F of negative one.
Everywhere we see an X we
put a negative one there.
So this is going to be
negative one squared.
So F of negative one is
equal to 12 divided by,
negative 12 divided by
negative one squared.
Well negative one squared is just one.
So it's gonna be negative 12 plus 15,
which is equal to three and we're done.
This thing is equal to three.